I was on a flight from Boston to L.A and
so it was five and a half hours sitting
next to a gentleman who for the entire
flight watched episodes of The Office
back to back to back to back and I was
like what do I do do I do I talk to him
about it how you know how do I interact
with him about you know should I even
say anything I had my covid mask on so I
was Incognito so after five hours of
watching The Office
I finally nudged him I was like oh it
seems like you like that show and he's
like yeah and I was like yeah I heard it
kind of sucks and he said well it starts
really slow the first season is kind of
questionable and I was slowly slowly
lowering my mask and then he recognized
me in his head exploded it took him like
47 seconds of talking to me and then all
of a sudden it was one of those like
face melting
brain explosions